has a leak confirmed that charlie cox's
daredevil is about to return to our
screens
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so when daredevil and jessica jones were
cancelled from netflix it was nothing to
do with the numbers it was nothing to do
with the popularity it was simply down
to a contract that disney had with
netflix to produce those shows that came
to an end and then basically the
emergence of disney plus unfortunately
though that contract that netflix had
with disney also had a little
caveat that basically meant disney
couldn't do anything with these projects
for a certain amount of time
is that period of time now coming to an
end because the rumors of charlie cox in
particular returning his daredevil seem
to be growing more and more
so a lot of the rumors are around
characters from the punisher jessica
jones and
um obviously the daredevil
the idea being that the the characters
that were created in those tv series
were so popular that if those characters
in particularly the punisher will return
to the mcu they would have to use those
actors and hopefully keep those series
as some element of canon but how would
they do that how would we do that would
it be a soft reboot
basically bring those same actors but
ignore kind of the original tv series
but bring the actors back into the mcu
and new storylines
could it be a continuation
where those original tv series from
netflix is still considered canon
and bring the characters back into the
mcu just as a continuation of their
story
or would it be a hard reboot where we
just see new actors new story and
basically everything to do with netflix
is ignored
the soft
reboot has kind of been the way a lot of
the rumors have gone
in that the actors from the punisher
jessica jones and daredevil could be
brought into the mcu but would never
really reference the storylines from the
defenders or their original series
charlie cox's portrayal of daredevil was
massively popular and there have been a
lot of rumors of him returning
actually for the spider-man movie no way
home there is a scene where happy aunt
may and spider-man pete parker are sat
around a table that looks like it's in a
legal setting and there's a fourth
character that we don't get to see is
that fourth character a lawyer
a lawyer defending peter parker because
god knows we know from how the last film
ended and what we've seen of the next
film that he's going to need some legal
aid
could that be
matt murdock defending him because let's
be honest he's in new york
if
peter parker is going to need us listen
if spider-man is going to need a lawyer
wouldn't it make sense that matt murdock
would be the man to step up and defend
him but how does that lead into
potential new daredevil series
well
there has been a leak through a twitter
account called rpk
so i found the original story on movie
web and i've been able to confirm that
this twitter account does have a bit of
a reputation for getting things right
so this leak
we can give it some credence
now this talent grid that's being
announced is a very early stage of
pre-production so we're not going to be
seeing daredevil anytime too soon
there is no way of knowing whether
charlie cox at the moment is still
involved because he is asked regularly
are you going to return as the daredevil
and he always answers
no comment not answering
he doesn't say no he doesn't say yes
he is very careful to make sure he
doesn't say anything now is that just
charlie cox
batting away news reports because he's
irritated by them is that charlie cox
being a bit political or is that charlie
cox doing what we see over and over and
over again with the mcu
being told not to say anything
have a look at any interview of any
actor except mark ruffalo who is
notoriously bad for um saying too much
in interviews um but the actors are
regularly say i've been told i'm not
allowed to say anything
because we always love a big surprise
spider-man character appearing when it
did in the mcu for the first time was
rumored but we none of us were really
sure until he actually appeared at the
end of the movie
this is the way mcu like to do it they
like to keep us guessing they like to
throw us curveballs they like to make us
think one thing is happening while
something else is happening over here i
think kevin feige
in his heart is a little bit of a
magician he loves a distraction so why
do we want to see dead evil return
anyway
well the first series particularly the
first series on netflix was phenomenal
and if we see a return of the kingpin
vincent dunaforio has to play that
character because he was unbelievable
as the kingpin
how many bad guys do you actually feel
sorry for at the end you know not very
often he was
the epitome of that character he lived
it and david tennant's portrayal as the
purple man in the first series of
jessica jones was really the best of the
netflix series
we they we had bad guys that weren't
evil they weren't doing it because they
had to they sort of they were sort of
doing it for a reason and the kingpin in
particular thought he was doing the
right thing
um the purple man you can sort of see
that after this character there's a
child anything he said people just did
and you know understand how
flawed humanity is that you know you
could go the way that that character
went in real life so i think
made you feel sympathetic towards both
of these villains
and that was one of the reasons why this
show was so phenomenal not only was it
brilliantly written and brilliantly
produced
it had a real depth to it and these
characters do have a depth of them that
the marvel has kind of been moving away
from recently movies like the eternals
and miss marvel those those superheroes
are getting so powerful now it's moving
away from sort of the humanity of a lot
of the earlier marvel products like iron
man iron man is a man he's weak he's
flawed and he creates this suit makes
himself into a superhero that's why he
was so phenomenally popular
i think there's a reason why eternals
maybe hasn't been quite as popular as
some of those other projects in the mcu
past because they've been moving
steadily away from the grounded reality
the grounded humanity of some of the
superheroes and into more
souped-up versions that are becoming you
know
unstoppable
bringing daredevil and jessica jones
back into the mcu really is an
opportunity for them to get back to some
of that more grounded reality
more grounded realistic sort of
superhero genre
the daredevil gets the crap kicked out
of him at the end of every single
episode but keeps fighting jessica jones
is a massive alcoholic and just a
completely flawed human being almost
every way but she keeps fighting she
keeps trying to learn she keeps trying
to figure out how to become a good
person even though in many ways she's
not
i'd love to see that come back into the
mcu and
i'd love to see them as part of in the
movies have little bits parts and little
cameos like in spider-man
but i'm hoping that this tweet and this
leak of information is honest i do
question why if it is real wasn't it
actually announced on disney plus day
just a couple of days ago but obviously
if it's in very early parts of
production then that's not going to
happen i mean echo was announced and
they've got an actor they've got a
storyline and they've already started
filming and that was announced at that
point
disney don't seem to announce things
until they're quite far along the line
so
that's probably the reason but tell me
what you think guys so please leave a
comment what do you think do you want to
see daredevil's return do you want to
see him in the movies do you want to see
him as a standalone series
when are we going to see it is a big
question i don't think it's going to be
for at least two years but let's fingers
crossed that we get something green lit
really soon and get something announced
really soon
if you are new to the channel by the way
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification share the video wherever
the hell you like join us on facebook
there is a link in the description and
also there's our discord server where
you can go and chat about all things
sci-fi
and finally thanks for watching and i
will see you next time
[Music]